yeah hi Brian I'm Michelle and I'm
really cool positioned that my husband
works with World Economic Forum it's
done it for on an offer almost 20 years
and through that I've been able to
attend so many meanings in Davos and
around the world and I've always gotten
to see amazing things happening for
example one time just meeting somebody
who just walked out of the session he
worked for a major rubber company and
they had just in the session asked him
to reduce emissions by a certain
percentage in the next five years and he
said I have no idea how I'm going to do
this but I have to do it because well I
committed to it there's always things
happening like that and in Davos and
when you get these amazing brains
together it's just great to see the
magic happen thanks